I think for my tiny village in the north
of Italy it was really young I love to
feel things and computer science was a
way to build simple to help yourself and
other people I came here to follow my
passion combining computer science and
biology my role is basically bringing
together scientists in all kinds of
disciplines in the life sciences with
biomedical sciences a colleague of mine
at maps Nicola in the South of France at
workshop he already seemed to be able to
combine computer science and life
sciences and he decided to hire me and
yaponets purple Guardian which is a
professor University of Cambridge they
was trying to understand our different
genes in blood cells interact with each
other and might lead for instance to
diseases such as leukemia we developed
the tool called combine to try to
understand how different genes can
regulate each other when we develop
combined we were wondering whether we
could apply the same technique that we
use in leukemia or seen a gluten
therefore we contacted teachers and they
were excited about it key genes of
research to support seed breeding
companies to develop new and improved
ropes
hi you that's a nutritional value to the
crop we're excited to work with Nicola
to see a combined tool can be applied to
plant genomics currently we're only
looking at genes themselves with this
tool we're also looking outside the
genes how do other parts of the genome
of the DNA affect a certain trait give
us more insight to how genes work we can
provide this knowledge to the plant
breeders to help them make better crops
I wanted to make this tool available for
other people to use since the beginning
was clear for us that Asia would provide
the scalability and robustness necessary
to deliver combined as a research of the
service we created them become because
we saw that there was not enough
software engineering the lifetime and we
want to empower life scientists with
innovative tool
use state-of-the-art software
engineering the challenge of this
century is transforming life science in
an engineering program and to do that
you need to bring engineering into life
science and although probably I will not
see the end of this journey I would like
to participate
[Music]